[Musique]
c'est quand même vachement pratique ce
petit vanne ça va les gars super tu es
au courant que tu es tout nu je peux pas
filmer le bas quoi vous êtes vraiment
douché là tout de suite là
comment tu fais toi je peux pas filmer
trop bas parce que moi j'en ai des
problèmes
qu'on a la petite douche c'est quand
même trop cool quoi ça a été toi la
petite douche ouais très bien un peu
fraîche mais ça va tu t'es lavé ou pas
aujourd'hui pour le deuxième week-end
avec un invité en plus et Monsieur Hervé
vaillant qui est avec nous
toujours Lélé nous avons toujours invité
on a perdu les hauts on n'a pas pu faire
les quatre jours on fera deux jours faut
toujours et demi je pense que ça va être
du haut niveau comme la semaine dernière
[Musique]
tu me trouves sexy dans mon chantier on
m'a dit que c'est un slip c'est pas un
slip c'est un short avec moi
[Musique]
Alice Cooper ça va tomber pourquoi c'est
pas français
vraiment la bonne mère il faut marcher
comme dans la neige non comme ça pareil
bien à plat bien à place quand tu tombes
tu es d'accord quand même un peu et toi
tu as pas du tout les chaussures faites
pour pas du tout du tout
incroyable vas-y montre-moi comment tu
fais montre-moi
tu peux glisser comme oui parce que
regarde si tu fais comme ça tu déroules
tu peux griser tu tombes alors que si tu
poses comme sur la Lune comme sur la
lune tu vois tu ne risques rien comme
avec ni la me trompe tu vois vas-y
n'attaque pas talon voilà à plat bien à
plat bien à plat c'est bien je suis fier
de toi tu m'écoutes bien tu me regardes
je veux regarder les plus beaux que toi
et tu vas faire le regarder la gueule ou
lui dans cette boule là dans cette
partie que lui il pense que ce nom là
c'est Kravitz alors que c'est Lenny
Lenny
toujours une histoire de sœur avec lui
c'est impressionnant
prime
[Musique]
c'est vachement bien c'est qu'ils
mettent des chiottes partout donc vous
pouvez pisser partout donc là tu es dans
le l'entrée du enfin presque 19 cadet et
les gens se posent les gens sont
détendus les gens sont à l'aise et tu
peux pas ton petit pipi parce qu'ici
comme la bière coule à flot et bien
voilà on peut on peut se vidanger d'un
peu partout et ça c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal
du coup ayant loupé mon oral de la
semaine dernière je suis revenu au
rattrapage et donc c'est le chanteur et
bassiste
[Musique]
coucou toi comment tu t'appelles
c'est vrai c'est ton métier c'est quoi
ton resto tu as un temps tu es quoi toi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Aurélien se fait désinfecter par le
tamilé voilà désinfecte des insectes le
trou voilà que ça se fait pas il rentre
en bon état qu'on lui coupe pas
l'oreille
c'est bon on a désinfecter tous les
trous tous les trous
[Musique]
[Rires]
le chocolat j'ai envie de le bouffer les
gars yeah on était une meute de trois
loups Hervé est parti faire une note de
4 loup merveilleux là Valérie on a une
mate de casse-cou
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez et comme je
bouffe toutes les 3h et en quantité
S
là tout de suite dernier jour tu étais
avec Alex
[Musique]
Arthur toi tu es bénévoles aux fesses
oui comment ça se passe toi tu fais quoi
en fait alors moi je fais partie de la
team Urbano
Urbano en fait on voulait les
couteaux suisses du festival que il y a
une histoire prévue dès qu'il y a du
retard quelque part et ben on intervient
on a une vingtaine et du coup on peut
aller sur
le site ou avec n'importe quel type pour
donner un coup en fait d'accord
tu vois tous les concerts tu es là toute
ma langue aux fesses c'est ça c'est un
peu le huile c'est que
nous offre le festival et en
contrepartie soit on monte pendant une
semaine toutes les structures soit on
fait le démontage moi je m'occupe des
montages et donc je reste une semaine
derrière le festoche
c'est une double édition et ben on a
fait les deux weekends et bien écoute tu
fais quoi tu vas démonter le veste c'est
ça et ça se passe comment le démontage
en fait ça se passe très bien merci
on va démonter toutes les cloches
barrières regardez dans les scènes on va
ramener toutes les barrières là qui sont
devant la cathédrale
ok on va tout ranger et comme je te
disais juste avant pendant le démontage
et ben il y a deux soirées qui sont
organisées une par le avec les restes du
des festivaliers sur le camping donc il
reste combien
bouteille pas ouverte ça nous fait une
bonne soirée et le jeudi soir au VIP
pour
tous ceux qui en fait ce qui ont
travaillé sur le festoche petite soirée
et souvent ça finit un docteur man euh
chez les Urbano donc ça veut dire qu'en
fait c'est pas fini après le SS pas ça
continue
ça commence à faire
mes deux semaines et on a encore une
semaine derrière mais il y a une
tellement une bonne ambiance que
franchement c'est du plaisir en fait sur
les bénévoles le FS c'est mort très bien
possible c'est le festival avec le plus
[Musique]
avant on était une meude de quatre loups
maintenant depuis que tu es là on est
une meute de 5 loups
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive tu as l'air
fatigué
[Musique]
comme des connards
tu as fait la bagarre
tu as fait du corps à corps
[Musique]
tu es vraiment mauvais c'est incroyable
ça c'est un batteur
[Musique]
tu vois ça casse claire bonsoir quand il
la frappe
[Musique]
comment ça se passe est-ce que tu es pas
un peu serré dans ton
gars
comment ça se passe ouais tu as mal
là ça commence à suer fort
[Musique]
et maintenant on a une mode de lourd et
si on se perd on sera une note de
[Musique]
ils vont se battre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde par soit par là-bas c'est
métal corner ou alors tout le monde sort
par là-bas et là-bas c'est la sortie du
festival en tout cas merci merci le
Hellfest parce que
grâce à vous 15 ans c'était dingue
concert de fous on a vu des choses de
dingue il y a des choses qu'on a loupé
je te le reconnaître parce que on n'a
pas fait que voir des concerts mais on a
sacrément bien rigolé donc merci
et je pense que une fois de plus même si
dans nos vidéos on a un peu des connards
on a vu des choses extraordinaires ça
déplacer des foules de fou et toutes les
équipes vous faites un boulot
extraordinaire que ce soit en terme
d'organisation de déco merci à tous les
bénévoles merci à l'équipe merci à tout
le monde merci à Roger moi qui je je
parle par mail pour pouvoir venir
justement ici et une fois de plus vous
êtes vous êtes extraordinaire et un
festival comme ça qui est plus exister
dans une petite ville comme Clisson
c'est juste un truc qui n'espérait
j'ai envie de me poignarder
devant un bon film c'est vrai que tu le
sais aussi de derrière
tu aimes pas le froid
c'est pas du froid c'est de l'eau c'est
pire